en 1941 l'allemagne nazie est au bord de
la faillite financière
cette époque l'union soviétique était
neutre mais staline avait une peur bleue
que l'allemagne les envahissent hitler
s'est servi de cette peur et il a décidé
de faire une demande d'emprunt à la
russie 81 million de reichsmarks en or
personne ne sait vraiment ce qui s'est
passé ensuite mais quelques semaines
plus tard hitler rompait le pacte de
non-agression et envahissent et l'union
soviétique
4 à necker 20 millions de morts mais
dans les années 50
des rumeurs commencent à circuler jusque
dans les plus hautes instances du
politburo staline aurait accordé
l'emprunt hitler aurait dépêché un
sous-marin staline aurait rempli de deux
tonnes d'or et l'aurait renvoyé
sauf que l'or n'est jamais arrivé et
hitler les envahir du coup du coup les
années ont passé et tout le monde a
oublié lors mais dans les années 80 un
laboratoire de recherches
océanographiques à découvert décret peu
profondes au large des côtes géorgienne
j'ai bossé pour une boîte qui s'appelle
agora marine management spécialisée dans
le sauvetage des pattes ils ont retrouvé
un sous marin allemand gisant sur l'une
de ces crêtes
il se trouve à peu près à 90 mètres de
fond donc accessible monsieur lewis
cette société pense que c'est le sous
marin allemand
en 2008 elle décide en informer les
géorgiens et leurs gouvernements elle
leur propose un deal et géorgiens 18
mois plus tard le conflit russo géorgien
éclate
les frontières se déplace et depuis les
deux pays se disputent la ligne de
partage des eaux les russies new york
sous marins se trouve là bas
les géorgiens ne connaissent pas sa
position exacte et agoras ne peut rien
faire tant qu'il ya ce conflit ils sont
pris entre la paperasse et les
stratégies des politiques pendant ce
temps le sous marin des nazis gît au
fond de la mer avec sa cargaison d'or
est ce qu'on peut savoir ce que vous me
voulez acheter nous un sous marin plat
qui a des contacts à sébastopol mais va
falloir mettre de l'argent sur la table
il va falloir sortir 180 milles et j'ai
besoin d'un équipage 50% composés de
russes
c'est un sous marin russe dont qu'ils
auront besoin de russes
j'encaisse 40% si vous trouvez jusqu'à
40 millions de dollars 20% si c'est au
dessus de 40 cm
ok